On one hand,
and this is the core of my message today,
I support Israel's right to national self defense.
It is an absolute right,
and Israel should be free to pursue
whatever solution Israel wants to pursue.
That is their judgment to make
without a second guessing them.
On the other hand,
I believe that that is Israel's decision to make,
and Israel's mission to carry out.
And the scope of the US involvement in this
needs to be providing diplomatic cover,
a diplomatic Iron Dome,
as I call it,
for Israel to carry that out,
but at the same time,
without military engagement.
So there are voices in multiple different camps
that would have criticisms
of some element of what I've said.
Many in the neocon movement in the United States,
or the old neocon movement,
would say that I should unapologetically,
unabashedly support US military engagement. I don't.
I'm an America first conservative,
but I also support
Israel pursuing an Israel first agenda.
And I think that if we
in the United States go back to our founding ideals.
I quoted George Washington's farewell speech
where he warned against
unnecessary foreign entanglements, but also
go back to David Ben Gurion's vision for Israel,
that's really
the true strength of the US Israel relationship.